you
hi everyone is cherry I am on Ches calm
and I'm going to play a 500 game just
got paired up alright let's try g6
playing against Hugo Oakland all right I
guess Kings Indian defense
let's play d6 don't want to see a
quickie 5 ah ha okay well let's castle
and get on with d5 I may try for a quick
Knight h5 I have to be aware of this
possibility I'm going to go straight in
for it yeah
so they've weakened g3 a little bit
maybe I could try to show that that's a
an issue at some point I don't know I
have to be careful of a g4 move and
that's potentially what's being lined up
right now
yeah the ready just kick my night
f-five takes bishop takes I get forked
f5 takes takes G for is going to get
wild let's get wild why not whoo that's
a big decision I have F 4 F 3 I'm really
drawn to F 4 here I don't necessarily
have to play off 3 either
I do like this as a start though let's
try it
f3 I don't have to I could stay flexible
here maybe I wouldn't mind seeing this
advance can try to play on the other
wing now let's shoot for that now
986 this is a really good piece I'm
pretty sure Knight d4 Knight c5 on this
move I have Queen h4 so opposite sides
castling let's start with Knight a 6
yeah
both of my Knights are on the edge but I
feel like they're my well I feel like
they're pretty good pieces so that move
isn't there an issue with that so you're
going to kick my knight and open up the
file for my rook if not I have a 4 and
then the knight jumping in here so
you're just challenging my knight
straight away
okay I may want to transfer this night
here one day
and I could play v6 as a start you know
what I like b6 yeah basically just
saying if you take I get the B file okay
so forget about the night getting to c5
I think taking Bishop d7 with a four is
another another fine idea important
moment I think this is this is an
important move because if I don't do
this there's a four Knight c3 Knight
here
so any for Bishop here I have a lockdown
on all pawn breaks you know this is this
is really good I think I'm able to now
buy myself some time to do whatever I
feel
[Music]
okay well they're clearly lining up this
advance could I try to make that a bit
more difficult to get in let's start
with this
I want a dark square bishop exchange by
the way and I'm fine with now moving my
queen the idea here is that now in this
advance comes I have Bishop h6 and I can
make quick use of bf4 Square and my
queen is developed and start with this
they could still look about look to drop
the knight into this square and I'm
going to look to exchange dark square
Bishop I want to basically play against
this guy they might try to pick up this
pawn with Bishop here yeah maybe that's
what they're shooting for um
can you really stop Bishop here for so
long
hmm
two minutes twenty two can I force this
like a plain night here and then Bishop
here and then threatened a night move
yeah let's do that
and I feel like I'm really doing too
much by playing rook here 95 I think
I'll hold off in PlayBook c8 as
extremely defensive as it looks
right here yeah I just want to get my
darks for a bishop active that's my
that's my main focus and I think I have
everything under control on this side
even if one day my a pond falls this
will give me some compensation that I
would have an open line for one of my
rooks
yeah I'm drawn to that early decision
and felt like pretty quick decision to
play Queen c2 that was a big moment in
the game because we're in a completely
different ball game here structurally
this is big very strategic play many
instances of fixed pawns present
opposite sides castling I'm looking to
go after the white king and yeah I
already have an open line towards the
king and now I'm caught up on time is
there a connection issue they've spent
quite a bit of time here I like my
position says that the connection is
excellent
hmm they'd really think yeah they're
thinking this one through
let's get on with this I have this
covered enough rook here and then trying
to get the clean here's that's kind of
tough all right let's start with this
and avoid the bishop exchange now
I can always I can always put three
pieces here to defend that's what
they're going for clean here all right
I'll just I'll babysit this pone I won't
give an inch is how where's the where's
the forward progress now I could drop
this night in here
is now bring my clean all the way back
let me inch the king up I don't know if
I want to really nail the knight in
there with a a four
I may need my knight to actually
contribute over here hmm what's the best
home for my king do I keep the structure
as is
now I want to keep this carpet for my
night if he's challenged I may want to
back up
I'm going to drop back
playing fast now alright they took off a
little bit of pressure here maybe I
could target this guy okay we'll repeat
a little bit
let's try over here let's see my queen
could do how about pressurized sea for
some
you know this Knight Returns here I mean
I'm pretty quick to come over here so
just a quick jab out that this pawn and
now I'll come over here there's no Queen
here now okay
could my knight do something hmm you
know what I have a different idea maybe
I put my Bishop pointing at this pawn
and I don't know if that works even
feels like they're trying to get this
break-in I may need my Knights help what
could he do though put my knight on this
square
okay I'm going to need my Knights help
going in for that I'm going to take him
out
can now get my queen over here I have a
dark square blockade yeah definitely
have that working for me I may want to
pitch this pawn and put my knight on c5
let's get them in a position we're very
even on time I don't know I guess I'll
do this now I want to sack I'm going to
sack
I think I need to Oh what was that about
they didn't take my rook they missed
that out okay now they're ready to take
my rook I'm on b2 now okay let's take
the rook we might clean and now I want
my night on b6 I think they just forgot
that could they they could take the
exchange there so now I'm definitely
making progress I'm going to completely
shut down this side of the board
improve my king now
22 seconds this is where the action is
they're offering a draw I don't want to
draw feel like I can win this
clean exchange and they're going to
activate the bishop okay I am slowly
making progress now we get the pawn
break in my king is going to help now
they're dropping some material though I
don't want that pawn let's do this yeah
I would have ended up in a pin nine
seconds my king is finally the last
piece that is entering the game and with
great effect I just went on time but
this is this is one position wise for
sure
hmm
yeah as mentioned I'm still thinking all
the way back to this moment right here
that was a very long game a 70 mover but
I'm looking right now at move number
nine I think that this was a huge
decision I get an F for
and notice a difference with the ponding
on h3 instead of h2 in this position
after the bishop moves if ever there's
some attack of this pond and I capture
white can recapture and open this file
for the rook this plays a role with you
know my knight because if there's ever a
strike now White has to take away from
the center and he's a real bother on h5
if he's pushed further well that weaken
was a square and he could jump into f4 I
was thinking that white should have sort
of Queen c2 played a capture and then
maybe g4 some type of gambit play get an
open line it's not like white is casted
on this side I am taking here and
developing
but my opponent has an open line
maybe clean here and then counsel
queenside that would definitely make for
an interesting game as I played out it
was super super strategic playing both
winnings a lot of well several moves
that were just trying to play quick and
solid it's tough to come up with a plan
but yeah I like the position that I got
once f3 was played in particular because
I knew things were going to transition
towards the Queen side so let me let me
bring up the computer and we'll we'll
dive into this one further okay this is
where I want to be and we have
the mcdonough of variation with h3
ruling out any bishop in on g4 and
there's also this aggressive intention
as well looking to maybe one day Castle
queenside and launched some attack
against my king so I got on with e5 have
to challenge these guys in some way the
middle pawn that's where white as weak
as that's a whole so one of these two
strikes needs to hit d5 it is and Knight
h5 straightaway
okay many different possibilities here
let's go with the 9h 5 and after night
there so this is already pretty critical
moment so f5 right now well first of all
it didn't like night g2e 2 it prefers
Bishop to e2 I was I was going to dive
right in you know even if one day I
dropped upon you know if this kind of
thing happens I don't I don't have any
concern over dropping this pawn well
even if he does fall I have the bishop
pair and a completely opened monster
diagonal monster bishop so that's what
I've that's what I would have done on
Bishop to e2 so they're just securing f4
I got on with that five it likes f5 and
what I want to do wants to take on their
five yeah
so this is important here takes I can't
take with the bishop because of g4 they
just double-check that there's nothing
fancy here after g4 that I have right
now it's losing so recapture at the pond
and is g4 move it's not it's not showing
g4 but now wants to return
I saw popped up Knight g1 and Knight f1
and now it does want to play g4 it
certainly felt like there'd be some kind
of compensation stripping open some
lines I mean yeah White's dropping upon
just like I was saying in the game where
if I end up if I ended up dropping my
apon I said well at least I'll have an
open line towards my opponent's king
well we could say similar on this wing
of the board as well okay if white drops
one of these guys at least it's an open
line towards my king
so that's what it likes and it's even
suggesting f4 but I probably in the game
I probably would have went for captures
mm but the other says this is kind of
scared the full compensation here and
probably given more time this evaluation
would even go up in you know White's
favor likes Bishop h3
removing an important defender of this
efore square yeah there's that would be
that's something to look out for so what
can I conclude here well if this would I
even want to go into this position again
after f4 all right zoom you have five
think I have to definitely play f5 so
from this point maybe I would consider
more f4 let's say instead of the wind of
a pond and opening up the H file for the
rook you know it's an important point
it's it's suggesting f4 here
now for Bishop d2 and that says run away
with the night okay
well that didn't happen we didn't have
so many pawn exchanges in this one super
lock structure Queen c2 that throw any
advantage away just doesn't like the
move f4 and now want Bishop d2
z5
is the right way forward my opponent at
this point is basically they have to go
queenside I have a lot of space over
here and it's it's an easy attack
against the white king if he goes Kings
side so one instructive moment I think
was I don't know how well I voiced it
during the game okay a five-night a six
two very good squares for the night they
want to step on d7 because then he's
kind of locked into only going to c5
it's true he obstructs the bishop that
the main point here is that I like to
have two two options for the night he's
on the edge but he's a well-positioned
here so a three
five and came to be one yeah it's it's
just going to be a struggle for white
unless there's some fancy tactic that
was missed throughout this seventy mover
I think I was always in control now that
now I have another decision here yeah
it's suggesting to take and probably
play Bishop d7 with a four yeah this and
then Queen c2 I don't know what was it
suggesting b5 I probably would have
played this though I wonder about c5 is
c5 a move here yeah
Gordan development I'm just trying to
see if there's a way that white can
crack open the position and help their
own pieces but I don't really see that
happening
and as it is now when I get in a four I
have one pawn controlling two and I
could one day now drop my knight in to
c5 I didn't have that option in the game
because I decided to play b6 and
recapture and I was clogging up the c5
square so this was definitely an
important moment right here when Knight
a four was played I should have a may be
considered Knight takes Knight and well
in no it's it's another it's another way
to play it Knight takes Knight with
Bishop d7 and a4 but I think how I
played it is fine too
though I wonder if the knight could
return and then sink into b5 yeah now
it's even suggesting this Knight play
here and keen on b5
yeah maybe maybe it's better to stay a
little bit flexible with my B and C
pawns at this moment take the night out
and play Bishop d7 with a four
yeah
changes there Knight takes e5 take
towards the center open up the D file
and yeah I still I mean I don't know if
we could really trust the evaluation
because objectively it's reading you
know equal but it feels so much easier
to play for black
okay night okay maybe this is an
important moment yeah it must be an
important moment because now now I get
this lockdown or my opponent is not able
to lock down the queenside so they
wanted to prevent this move but I guess
what was more important is Knight c3 and
on Bishop to d7 I think the move a4 is
strong here it's not suggesting a4 but
I'd like to illustrate this this is a
key moment a 4 is in and now next well
it's now suggesting I play c6 something
I don't I'd like to shy away from
because it's opening up this file for
the rook it's opening up this square for
the knight and it's making my deep on
vulnerable so my idea here is that the
idea that I'm trying to share here is
that if Knight c3 was played instead of
f3 light will be in time to lock down on
d5 and because of this I won't have play
against their King on this wing this is
basically shut down on this side of the
board now and I guess I'd have to be
going with c6 as the computers pointing
out because the alternative is to then
sit in wait and it will be white who is
then playing against my King prepping
some type of advance on this wing of the
board
things could have turned around quite a
bit if white was a little bit more
timely with this Knight c3 and a4 idea
but by first playing f3 this allowed me
to play first
a4 and I mean he actually saw how it
played out in the game where you know
eventually the knight dropped in here I
took it out and because I have my pot on
a4 he's still there to restrict these
two and I could even work one day with
the a5 square
it's pretty long-term stuff here but it
it plays a big role if this bond is on
this square and micron is still here
completely different ballgame
completely
okay now it feels like I just have
complete control here I'm just kind of
skimming through I don't think anything
fancy was missed here yeah I wanted to
provoke the bishop going back so in the
event of this I can gain quick access to
what would then be a hole in White's
position if this guy ever moves now this
becomes a very key square Bishop h6 into
f4 and I can now look to target the F
pawn so
yeah I don't think that that anything
was missed here
have to make any suggestions for white
especially once I get the dark square
bishop soft my bad bishop
so you know they're trying to target my
pawn but I have I'm always there in time
to support him eventually put a third
attacker on it but
who is able to double up and defend
so dark square bishop Soph I just want
to see how the evaluations may be
changing it's a little bit more than a
pawn advantage for me clean takes yeah
and a little bit of shuffling here I
jump in
I go elsewhere yeah a little bit of
floundering here I want to get to a
point where it maybe there's some tactic
now that I have some pieces over near
the Queen side
let's see right there
the take came out right away you know
now I have this square to work with
wants to return with the night in to h5
okay at one point I don't think I've
voice in the game but I wanted to play
c4 and then jump my knight in here but I
thought that Y could maybe sack back the
exchange maybe I could just quickly
highlight that because once I end up
winning this ponta they didn't take my
rook is kind of just simple then it's
kind of tough if this pawn ever moves I
mean they're subjecting their King to
some problems there
and 90 d7 and this is where I captured
the pond now first I wanted to lock make
sure the other side the bird was locked
out now I even took it here it's not
really a fan of that capture
but and I know I kind of had an eye on
the clock at that stage it probably
would have been better to mmm
was going to say maybe first lock up
this side of the board get in
h4 and only then go in for this
well one thing that's maybe interesting
is that if the queens are off here I
would definitely not want to have my
pawn on h4 because I would prefer to
keep this path open for my King to put
some pressure on g2 you could see that
happen
the Queen's weren't on the board if
somehow there was a queen exchange clean
here Queen here and you know their
exchange one day I would like to have
this option open
okay well I went in for a pawn grab and
they didn't take it back
so it's just downhill from here
and by this time after Brook here you
can't take in even after Bishop to c4 I
can't take still because there's that
fork and I could still keep the rook
there and maybe do something else
I just exchanged and now it's just gone
from here
but uh right around this point yeah
right around this point whether my
knight was here I was thinking about
this and after captures here but there's
this extensive that to give the exchange
back and now my opponent has a minor
piece and two pawns for the rook and now
they're on the offensive all of a sudden
this pawn is under fire this bishop will
become very active and I don't know how
my Brooks even get active
they're very clumsy right now
so just wanted to point that out it was
an idea it was a thought but they're
they're going to be quick to invest a
material back just to kind of crash
through and go on the offensive
so yeah from here was not too difficult
once I scooped up that a d5 pawn and
also once the Queen's were off my King
was able to contribute so on the lock
down the side of the board and I can run
over with my king
they're just going back and forth with
the King not too much you can do is
white so I don't think anything's
changing here you have at the Queen's
off it's now minus two
close to it you know and I'm certain
that there isn't anything missed from
here on out yeah
just one little trick takes here there's
Bishop here so
even still do that apparently King here
and then I could push my pawn up if work
here I could always push with c4
no reason to you actually it's reading a
zero because I can never get out of this
pin how do I break the pin
rook c5 well first off king c5 runs into
it gets in the rooks way there's bishop
or rook takes I can never get out of
this pin so yeah there's no there was no
rush with taking that pawn that's why I
just instinctually look to improve my
King see for stuff and only at a later
stage pick this guy up and I will not be
in a pin then and they just timed out at
that point
okay well sometimes it does happen like
that where it turns strategic we
definitely got to see a strategic game
in this one out of the Kings Indian
defense a katana of
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in a comment
section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye